[Music]
in undervalued news Oh submitted by
Connie a homeowners whose real estate
website Zillow and says zestimate is
nonsense
oh hey I love Zillow by the way really I
[ __ ] loves why do you love it what is
it little I love doing I feel like after
Instagram pillows the next app that own
Instagram Yelp and Zillow that's the
house oh you guys no no no you gotta
like this a house having it stuff so
Bilbo
no because you have to Fu fun property
at you like you have to sign all this
other BS in order to see the property
and says like I just want to see the
photo no you can't you don't have to
yeah it depends on that Pulitzer yeah oh
you could go under you can look for rent
you could look to buy you can see all
the pictures it's super updated I've
been looking at what is it low and you
people go along and there's a lot of
info like uh like school districts the
average median salary income like
there's all kinds of stuff about that
entire neighborhood Zillow is the real
estate app oh thank you yeah it's done
it's pretty cool because um you know how
we like to go onto vacation and travel
at different places and we Airbnb and
the other day when we were in Hawaii it
was like I wonder how much this health
cost and endo show you like holy crap
the house last sold for two million
dollars or whatever and then you see all
in the area like this one's selling for
3 million and whatnot and you're like
wow imagine so specifically for people
looking to purchase real estate for rent
I never got anything on it but I like to
dream and that's like right after Yelp
and Instagram for you yep Instagram is
one of my friends doing because I don't
want to hang out with them so let me
just ah we are we classify them know
it's kind of like it's kind of like oh
I'm too tired of go out and hang out
with you guys but like let me see let me
keep updated in your life Oh
kind of like that right and a Yelp is uh
hungry so like let me order some [ __ ]
and then Zillow's like I wish I was here
to make yourself feel bad you know what
kind of think of it I'm [ __ ] dreaming
all day while I'm just inside somewhere
I was over here that's America's tagline
exactly that so this is woman named
Barbara Barbara Bush published she is
filing a lawsuit against Zillow because
she's been trying to sell her townhouse
for some time now and her townhouse is
at the value of six hundred twenty six
thousand dollars right and what Zillow
Agusan she said when she got an
appraised so that's what she's saying is
what her home is worth and that's around
the same price as she paid for it in
2009 but what I'm saying is who said
though she soon or she had an appraised
she's saying because she's also a real
estate agent yeah oh but she knows her
so she knows what's up she ain't just
the person that like I bought it for
this much so you go by me just cuz she's
a realtor truly she's not our praises
exactly go on proceed she's real she's
calling herself a real estate lawyer
that'll me [ __ ] gold addict word fair
title yeah so for her she was just say
that yeah like my house is worth us six
hundred twenty six thousand dollars on
Zillow with their estimate it says that
it's five hundred sixty two thousand
dollars and so for her she's like well
no like that's not the value what
destiny does yeah it gives you an
estimate of like how much the homes cost
in this particular area but the thing is
that it's not accurate and because it's
not accurate it's really throwing off
like the prices around in that
neighborhood so it's just like you know
house estimate though it's an estimate
right it's not like precise limit yeah
and if they call it as estimate to let
you know it's their estimate yeah their
own personal opinion yeah they made up a
words bill didn't even say estimate it
says estimate it's not Zillow's fault
it's stupid home buyers fault that goal
and rely on Zillow and say like your
house should cost five hundred thousand
because that's what Zillow told me in
her case she was saying that yeah you
know like estimate they are like
estimates to help like potential
homebuyers like oh you know I want to
get this house right I like it but the
thing is that
what we're saying is that Zillow doesn't
have the license to give out these
estimates they're not giving our
instruments you're giving out there's
estimate that's my new point that's like
sim suing me like I go to a house how
might you know what I only like house
with swimming pools so the best of it
for this house for me half a million
dollars they're going to come sue me and
my mother [ __ ] I don't say estimate is
my best of it yeah
you can't [ __ ] sue me from my own
personal opinion and so what farmers
continue to say is look at tripping as
Barbara Zillow should be like us to
perform these estimates before like
offering these kinds of estimates right
and also the fact that like it like
before they even put up a price to be
like made public like they should
actually run it by to the homeowners
first see if that price is okay with
them I understand that especially it's
like the app gets super popular where
people are relying on it for a
particular subject information but I
think for the home buying process I mean
you can go to that right but you still
have to check out the property and then
once you're getting ready to sign
paperwork then a third party which is
the appraiser they come and then they
tell you oh actually it's they'll tell
the person telling it right like the be
like oh actually you wanted it this much
but it's not that it's valued at this
much and then the buyer has the
opportunity like oh yeah then what am I
going to pay what thereat you don't it
means with a 30 I guess it's just more
so like the perspective is in negative
view for like the homeowner because if
it devalues their home in terms of
expectation for a buyer then already
going to be like a more difficult sell
they don't even want to like look at the
house yeah because they'll be like oh
it's too expensive if they're like hey
you know I'm down to have a conversation
with you because your house is half a
million dollars and the person's like
well actually it's like six hundred
thousand and the person's like oh watch
me and it's kind of like you know I mean
if they would have had closer to effect
I mean that's a big big margin right
percentage-wise it's like it's like
those wacky weird cases of Yelp where
maybe I started up this restaurant and I
have a passion for cooking this type of
singing but I happen to make this other
type of thing that it's really good
everybody only comes here for this
because it's popularized by Yelp so now
I'm spending my entire day cooking
something I'm not super passionate about
because that's how like the
ended up making my I guess my lifestyle
you want it top time everybody's here
with you see yell that no but it just
kind of you know I mean like the power
of something like that like a not
necessarily inaccuracies in this
particular but it becomes a demand or
like they create a standard and they
create a world of yeah if it not
authorized yeah yeah I don't know sue is
like the right way to go about it I
don't think so I think maybe Zillow
should edge in the cake
and whoever signs up says this is as
estimate you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] go to a
real praiser for the price of this house
I'm sure they have that disclaimer dude
it's really I've never seen it there's a
lot I don't know the settlement of
course though will probably really just
come down to no actually no actual money
going to Barbara but then like dem
needing to put like the Surgeon General
warning at a clearer place on the
website like zestimate was made up you
idiot the main point for Barbara's
argument is that those estimates are
misleading to the to the consumers and
they're like you know when they ask you
know what she's also crying though
because it's lower
so if hers estimate said 800,000 soon
she would have the same you know she
would be quiet wouldn't be like this is
an outrage yeah use estimate how dare
you over value my home my body for six
fundraisers and I have prayed that 650
how dare you [ __ ] make it 800,000 I
don't want any customers coming in here
with that 800 [ __ ]
yeah I'm trying to give me more money
than ask for [ __ ] that this is not right
being this article and just
understanding her situation what she
saying is that for them for the time
being she's not seeking any monetary
damages all she just wants is they need
to make their [ __ ] right no yeah it is
either
Zillo removed the Zestimate or at least
amended I like those estimates I love
please keep it because what the
Zestimate does is it tells you like
based off of homes that sold within that
area this is what what the average price
of homes are yes and it's so it's
supposed to be highly inaccurate I
wouldn't want it to go there's a lot of
things that aren't accounted for so for
example the house that we just bought in
the area its
way above this estimate because you're
not going to account for how new iPad is
so our pad is a brand new home so of
course it's going to be way more
expensive but to people that don't care
about stuff like that then it doesn't
really matter but for someone that is
looking for a new house they're going to
know that yes to pay a little bit more
for a brand new house right so that's
the same exactly it's it actually
depends on the value so that which is
why there's no way to accurately have a
good estimate or estimate how about this
nobody in LA can afford their own home
that shit's expensive
yeah how about bad not currently can't
afford it unless you said yep
working out please see here's my game
time I live in LA right juga I'll buy a
patch of land right where we were right
where haha a maybe or you live in LA and
by the Icelandic line some more big some
somewhere beautiful in between Hawaii
and Havana oh that's a good one
somewhere Landy okay okay this is no
more Landy okay I'm a freaking terraform
that [ __ ] which means if it's a
desolate or messed-up area I'm going to
vegetate that [ __ ] make it beautiful so
I'll be super city and super wilderness
and I can balance my life because I'll
find an equilibrium there dude so one is
I live in the city like a bougie luxury
guy and I go oh I can't take this
my life is to first world then I go and
live in a grass hut and eat some worms
now I'm back to the natural man but now
I need my key to do that what I'm going
to go back in it on the the place well
I've been looking and I think what I can
afford is property at the half a million
value because of what my monthly is but
they're killing it it's only a couple
thousand if you do it right oh that's if
you know what I don't
but what I really want is in a couple
million range I know all the house I
have a look at that I really want their
life to be a formula I know have you
guys ever done this on Zillow where you
just max it out to see what the
possibilities are in this world I found
a house in the Hollywood Hills if you
want to rent it's 70 G's a month rent to
rent what do you mean that's it that's
what about its hold tires worth of
Ballarat hey guys hope you enjoyed that
episode please don't miss a beat and
subscribe so the Phaedo subscribe you
don't know when a new video is uploaded
but for more videos click up here
[Music]